Michael Finkel du New York Times pense
qu'après trois ans, vous pouvez m'appeler Mike,
voici un jour de congé maintenant, en fait,
aller au bureau oh je t'aime cet
article parlait de sauver la
vie des jeunes vous avez dit écrivez-le j'ai dit
écrivez-le pas  j'ai fait de mon mieux avec
ce que j'avais tu as un avenir devant
toi Mike mais pas ici tu sais pour être
honnête je suis soulagé que ce soit fini avec le
temps où il s'est transformé en un vrai connard
travaillant pour eux
bonjour salut je suis  un journaliste de The
Oregonian, je voulais avoir votre avis sur
l'histoire de Christian Longo qui a
assassiné toute sa famille pourquoi me dites-vous
cela parce que quand ils l'ont
agressé, il a dit qu'il était Mike
Finkel du New York Times a-t-il dit
quelque chose  du tout pourquoi il prétendait
être moi, j'espérais que vous pourriez
me dire qu'il n'était qu'un gars ordinaire, un
homme intelligent et sain d'esprit,
il rentre à la maison un soir et tue sa
femme et ses enfants, cela n'a aucun sens
merci de me voir mr  .  longtemps Connie
Chris alors pourquoi moi
j'ai suivi toute ta carrière je suppose que
je me sentais comme une nouvelle année je veux te dire
ma version de cela
seulement toi peut-être qu'à ce stade ça n'a pas
d'importance  toi,
c'est une histoire unique dans une vie ne
vois-tu pas que c'est une seconde chance tu es
un paria ce n'est pas l'homme que je
voulais être aucun de nous n'est l'homme qu'il veut
être bonjour Jill hé ravi de rencontrer  tu honores
les Mike, il a été un véritable ami pour moi,
j'espérais juste que nous pourrions être amis Tim, je
crois que nous faisons avec un
homme exceptionnellement dangereux,
tu avais le choix entre tant d'histoires à
raconter et tu as choisi la sienne en fait, il
m'a choisi.  Je ne t'ai pas choisi, il t'a utilisé, nous
pensons qu'il fait partie d'un plan de match plus important,
ce n'est pas seulement à propos de moi
qui dois-tu protéger
et dire que tu penses qu'il est innocent - Mia,
toute ma réputation sur l'eau ne
m'abandonne pas  tu vas vraiment être
l'homme qui pourrait le libérer Chris
as-tu fait ton ringard